our first speaker is Tim twohill uh he
is 6
foot7 uh and is actually never played
basketball in any organized fashion uh
but Minister golf done some some some
Min golf Tim come on come on out all
right thank you Jake introduction
introduction the way that was supposed
to go was you know if it stands that I
play basketball because I'm tall then it
stands the reason that maybe someone
plays miniature golf because they're not
that's it was supposed to be a joke uh
so but yeah so I'm Tim tohill I'm the
CTO of cerice group and I'm here to talk
today about some work that I did to
integrate a large language Model A
Knowledge Graph platform that I built so
um this is primarily focused on
development and dat uh I hear my mic
going in and out so that might distract
me a little bit but um so yeah this is
primarily focused on this is D4 but I'm
focusing on the development data parts
uh so what's next so I want to talk a
little bit about my motivation for
trying to integrate an llm with
Knowledge Graph platform uh I also want
to talk about why we why you would use a
Knowledge Graph and then uh the the
process that I use to integrate the
large language model with the knowledge
graph platform and finally I'll do I'll
bring up the the software platform that
I developed and show
uh uh to answer questions and then
finally if there's time I'm going to go
over some ideas I've had for how to
improve this okay so I want to set the
stage um large language models are
probabilistic uh if you've ever used
chat GPT it's been very much popularized
um you'll you'll know that for a given
prompt that you give it a question that
you ask it'll produce different output
uh every time you ask the same thing not
not every time but it can produce
different output and this is because
llms are essentially a distribution of
probabilities across tokens and for the
sake of this talk you can think of as a
token as a word uh tokens are not words
which is one of the reasons a large
language model can make upwards or
hallucinate um but the output's
probabilistic and not predictable um so
what it's doing is it's performing a
completion and large language models
have been trained on high volumes of
natural language texts or the ones that
we hear about are Chang so so like the
entire Corpus of Wikipedia um
source of training for these models so
uh and based on that training it builds
the probability of what words would
follow given a prompt databases on the
other hand give you the data that you
put into it so uh it the queries that
you would run on a database to get data
out of it um they they have their own
language so it's not natural language
it's not like talking to it you have to
actually learn the query language that
query language has a has a strict syntax
so you have to get it right
and so um it can be there can be more of
a learning curve with uh running queries
to uh get data out of your database but
the data that you get out of it will be
exactly what you put into
it okay so why did I want to try to
integrate AAR language model with our
knowledge graph platform Knowledge Graph
platform excuse me uh so the first
reason was to try to make it easier to
write queries or draft queries so I
wanted to the user to be able to ask a
natural language question something like
how many people are in my database or
are represented in my database and have
it automatically produce a query that
would answer that question um an
alternative approach that I that might
seem more intuitive is that you could
train a large language model on the DAT
all the data in your database but as
I those models probabilistic so if you
asked it a question that requires an
accurate answer uh because the output is
probabilistic um it may not be an
accurate answer and often when you use a
database you want to get accurate
answers uh secondly is that because we
rely on the llm to to give us accurate
answers from data in our database we
could maybe uh use it to produce a query
that would give us those answers so uh
if it can write a query that would
answer those questions uh then we'll get
you know answers to questions based on
the contents of our database and then
finally uh not only do you have to know
how to write the query and like I was
saying the syntax for the query but you
also have to know the data model so if
you are familiar with a database like
like a SQL database it has tables and
those tables have columns and you have
to know what those columns are so that
you can know how to write your query and
what constraints to to include in your
query so that the data you get back will
be what you
need so why knowledge graphs so
knowledge graphs provide uh compared to
other database uh or that is compared to
other data models the knowledge graph
provides a more intuitive uh model for
for understanding what's in your
database um and as it turns out it's
also more intuitive for
llms um they they expressive uh
structure and schema so um that from the
experiments that I ran and the test that
I've done uh that made them uh made made
it so that an llm could could write or
write a query for you that uh had a
greater likelihood of giving you the the
results that you need so some of the
other database types are like relational
databases and they use
uh the SQL language for writing queries
and so I I tested using relational
databases and asking the llm to write
SQL queries for me I tested with some no
SQL databases just to compare and then
finally I I tested with some some graph
databases um so another reason for
knowledge graphs is that they are more
they more naturally correspond to domain
ontologies and um domain ontologies are
a a a especially when they're
standardized they break down a domain of
knowledge into its constituent
components and the data model of a
Knowledge Graph uh just aligns with that
more naturally and as it turns out that
the more you align your data model to a
standardized domain ontology again the
greater likelihood there will be that it
will produce a query for you uh given a
natural language question uh that
actually answers the
question and uh this is another example
of how line to a domain ontology here
you can see that the knowledge graph
schema is sort of subordinated or or is
an instantiation of the data within it
is an instantiation of the entities
represented in the
ontology and then also knowledge graphs
can can sometimes be a a good first
stage for onboarding new data sets so uh
data data can come in lots of different
formats and there are lots of different
uh kinds of formats like hierarchical
formats tabular formats uh some UNR text
and uh those different formats uh can
make it difficult to ascertain what's in
the data when you look at it so the
example I'm showing here uh which I know
is probably hard to see on the screen
but this is a uh database with uh
from a data set that we loaded into our
knowledge graph it's called the ubo data
set it contains a lot of information
about companies and other entities that
are related to those companies and it's
a very hierarchical and just looking at
it's it's difficult to ascertain what's
in there and you also have to iterate
over a lot of the data to get a comp
ensive understanding of all the entities
and relationships that are represented
in it so if you bring that entire thing
into a Knowledge Graph as you can see
it's becomes clearer and more
comprehensive to see what's in that
data so and finally as it turns out
knowledge graphs seem to be they lend
themselves to simpler prompt engineering
and as I've said before a greater
likelihood of generating a correct query
given a natural language uh question or
prompt so I wanted to compare uh this
with with something like s database
because that's what I did when I set out
to integrate the llm with the prograph
platform uh that I built so uh this is a
one to many relationship in a SQL
database in order to answer a question
uh you would have to the question I'm
showing here like Howers were placed by
John Smith you would write a a select
statement that uh joins the order table
to the customer table based on the
customer ID stored in both
tables uh for many many to relationships
which are common in SQL databases as
well um the query gets more complex you
have to do more joint operations you
have to know uh what the identifiers are
in each table and and in order for the
large language model to produce the qu
correct query it also has to understand
which one of these identifiers to use to
perform this joint and in the testing
that I did I found that getting those
identifiers were correct was one of the
was one of the ways that it would it
would not produce the correct query it
wouldn't understand which columns were
used as
identifiers with the knowledge graph uh
the identifiers that are used to relate
entities that whole thing is abstracted
away uh so when you go to write a query
for a Knowledge Graph it's more
expressive and you're not dealing with
those primary foreign keys or those
identifiers for entities to relate them
together in the query so answering that
same question with the knowledge graph
this is a graph traval uh language
called Gremlin that I'm showing here
it's the language that we use in the in
the knowled platform I've
and as you can see the the query here is
a bit simpler and more expressive we
have labels on the relationships between
the customers and the orders and the
orders and the product and now to answer
this question I can write a like this
which is more intuitive and
expressive so to compare and contrast
those two uh if the large language model
had to write a query to answer the same
question uh using the different database
types that I've shown here this this is
this is the difference between them and
so as I found in in uh my testing and
experimentation with this uh it the the
large language model was was uh produced
more accurate queries uh when it was
when it was uh using a Knowledge
Graph so integrating large language
models with knowledge graphs and and so
I'm going to go into the process the the
initial process that I developed for
that the algorithm uh but one
consideration I wanted to touch on was
uh whether the language large language
use one that's on Prem or use ass sass
so assas is software as a service that's
like open AI um so it
requires and our knowledge graph
platform gets deployed or might be
deployed on networks that do not have
internet connectivity and so as a result
it needs to include the large language
model capability with it so I had
consideration for actually running and
hosting the large language model myself
I got uh as far as the GPT 3 .5 I was
able to run that and there are Hardware
considerations with that performance
considerations so um th those were some
of the things I dealt with when I when I
did this
integration and then finally to well not
finally um and then some of the other
challenges are faced were in regards to
the the Sy syntatic validity of the
query that's produced and testing that
maybe ahead of time uh and then also the
correctness of the query for answering
the question so uh this is something
that I'm not sure I'll will be able to
to nail down so to speak in that the
user will have to be somewhat familiar
with the query language in order to know
whether or not it's correct uh or to run
it and know if the data they're seeing
actually answers their question uh and
then goes back and iterates again on
developing that query um in either case
it definitely helps as I found to have
the large language model give you a head
start to develop that query and then you
can go back and refine from there uh and
then we're going to look at a prompt
engineering example not here soon as far
as one of the challenges I faced when
when doing this um prompt engineering is
an iterative process it it feels like an
experimental process uh I I try
different different approaches uh to to
sort of uh prompt the model to know
about the schema to know what all the
properties were of entities so that it
could generate the correct query um it
also requires that you you parse the
output because the large language model
is probabilistic uh it's not consistent
with what it produces um almost every
time it did include a query but that
query could have been surrounded by
other natural language texts so I had to
to develop a way to to extract that
query out of the natural language text
out of the output and then show that to
the user and give the user the option to
run the
query so here's the the three steps
generally that are performed to to
prompt the large language model to
automatically generate queries one is to
get the schema and format the schema uh
for the llm specifically and then prompt
it with both the schema and the the
natural language question that the user
uh entered into the
system so here's uh getting the schema
this is a uh the again this is like the
first iteration of this integration so
uh very simple function to ask the
property graph for its schema and uh
this is a small example of the output
that it produces this is a more
realistic example uh just basically a
blob of text um but it's what this is
doing is it's defining the schema it's
defining all the properties and the
types of those properties and in order
to prompt the LM I couldn't use all this
especially for smaller models um smaller
models have a smaller uh token length
that they support so you're going to
have to uh for the schema of your
database uh you need to remove anything
that's extraneous anything that isn't
going to help the llm know about your
schema so that's what I did so the
second step is to format this and this
is just a couple of simple functions to
remove extraneous stuff that doesn't
help like defining indexes defining
partitions within your data and so this
uh this is the function a very
rudimentary function for doing that and
then finally prompting the llm and in
this case I'm using open AI as an
example uh so I pass in schema that was
formatted and then I pass in the Pro the
prompt from the user and then the llm
produces an output and then I process
that output to extract the query and
show that to the user so I'm going to
bring this together and show it in the
platform that I developed uh it's called
skg stands for a semantic Knowledge
Graph um so this is the sort of the
query interface for that
platform um earlier I showed the
database that we loaded and and there
was just a picture of it uh so that had
about 650,000 companies represented in
it along with um like directors of the
company and um add the street addresses
for the company and all that so I took
that and loaded it into our our
knowledge graph and the initial schema
for it is um is basically representative
of the the relationships and entities in
the actual raw data set itself in the
database so I'm going to show you
that
schema and so here's here's the
resulting schema from that again this is
just the first stage of that uh loading
process uh from here we would take it
and refine this model take out stuff
that we don't really need because we're
not going to be asking questions about
them but uh as you can see there's
there's a company entity it shows
advisers for the company it shows
persons with significant control um
these are all entities represented in
the knowledge graph so normally uh and
and I built this platform before I
integrated the large language model so
normally you would have had to write a
query here and um you'd have to know the
gremlin query language you would have to
know how to write a graph traversal and
what that means um and so I'm going to
this is a very simple query I'll run
that basically says give me back back
any 10 entities and Traverse it uh to
show me what's connected to them so uh
this is an example of of a a result of
that
query so uh Big Blob of data here I'm
going to zoom in so we can see these
entities and what they're connected to
we're currently working on the next
version of this platform so the
visualization is going to get better and
better uh but yeah you can see that this
is a company uh land in site and and you
can see all the entities related to it
so one of the analy questions we had for
one of the reasons we wanted to um load
this data set was because we wanted to
identify uh companies that might have
any connections to China so
um I'm going to write a natural language
query uh well and so so the query
interface here um I wanted to show the
user the schema uh so they could see the
entities and relationships in their
Knowledge Graph and get an idea of the
kinds of questions uh they would be able
to ask like what what's in here as they
write their natural language query um
obviously you're not going to be able to
ask questions about entities that aren't
in here so um so an example query to
answer that China question something
like um so we've got persons with
significant control so let's look that
oops so which
companies uh have persons with
significant control
uh located in
China sorry I used this
key
okay yeah well you know there's a lot of
ways that you can um improve the
performance you can uh modify parameters
that you pass in to the llm like the
temperature and the seed value and uh
again if there's time I'll be talking
about those um so here's the query that
it generated uh it looks like it's
country of residence yeah right so let's
run this I added this ability to test it
and this basically tests the syntatic
validity of the query ahead of time
before you run it uh later versions as
we're improving this and and we are
making significant improvements uh we
don't think we we're going to need that
so I'm just going to run this see what
happen like U so it it filtered on
persons with significant control country
of residence is China and these are the
companies that have those connections so
it answered the query and gave us back
uh the companies that have those
connections um and you can go and
explore this for verse These entities
and all that so I wanted to go back and
talk about um some some areas of
improvement that we're working on um ask
question no questions yet but but
afterwards yeah I appreciate it do cam
thank you yeah um so so one of the ways
to make this better is is just using
consistent naming conventions for like
the property names The Entity names and
the relationships um aligning to The
Domain ontology that I talked about
before helps with that because that if
if you if you work to align your data
model to a domain ontology your your
naming conventions will follow suit
naturally um and then finally and this
is one that
I'm here soon in the next version of our
software is associating the parameters
used uh in prompts so like the
temperature which temperature setting is
is determining how how random that
output's going to be so if it's
consistently producing a good query you
could probably reduce the temperature so
that it is consistent every time but um
you can also modify the seed which is if
as programmers know the seed values is
like the seed for a random number
generator pseudo random number so you
give it a seed value it's guaranteed to
produce output that is that looks random
and behaves random but is the same every
time given the same seed and so you can
use that with a large language model
but also uh often the same query gets
run U for a given like a Knowledge Graph
often users will run the same query just
phrased differently so maybe a cosine
similarity of the natural language
queries and then associate the uh using
user feedback so the like the user gives
a thumbs up on the query that was
generated you get enough of those if two
natural language queries have the same
cosine Sim have have a good cosine
similarity then uh you could just
shortcut and use the one that was
already generated that we know was
correct so these are some um some
approaches we're taking to to make this
capability uh better leveraging llms so
that's it uh my time's up so thanks
everybody I appreciate
it